pierre et luce célèbrent leur
anniversaire de mariage dans un
restaurant italien renommé bonne part de
bon vin mais mauvais service marco leurs
serveurs manqué d'expérience à la fin de
la soirée pierre choisi de donner 15 %
de pourboire même si le service ne
valait pas sa part gardant son relevé il
découvre que le pourboire été calculé
sur le montant total incluant les taxes
son pourboire de 15% équivaut donc à 17
% du prix du repas
encore une erreur de serveurs
inexpérimentés non en général les
terminaux sont programmées ainsi ça n'a
rien d'illégal mais ça surprend quand on
l'apprend depuis peu certains terminaux
permettent de donner un pourboire avant
les taxes mais pas dans ce resto pour
vraiment donné 15 % vous pouvez choisir
le pourboire en argent
encore un truc multiplier le montant de
la tps par 3 ou encore au québec
vous pouvez donner 13% ce qui est égal à
15 % avant taxes le fin mot de
l'histoire pour les pourboires
sachez calculé à moins de vouloir offrir
plus à marco